as the sun lit up the sky over
Scotland's West Coast a Canadian C-17
Globe Master pierced through the clouds
the crew from Trenton's 429 transport
Squadron are on a delivery mission in
support of Ukraine
we don't have direct contact with
Ukraine
the things that we're bringing end up
going there and then supporting them
Canada doesn't fly directly into Ukraine
relying instead on routes through
neighboring countries Global News has
agreed not to name the destination for
safety and operational concerns inside
these boxes some of the latest promises
from Canadian officials warm winter
clothes batteries cameras and these are
items that we've heard Canada's defense
minister
just back in October
unlike the UK and U.S Canada rarely
shares images of donated supplies or
details about deliveries the air Task
Force Commander who is also the co-pilot
says air operations at a Prestwick
Scotland have become increasingly
important since March Canadian aircraft
have moved 5 million pounds of Allied
and partner supplies the majority has
been to assist Ukraine this delivery
however on Remembrance Day is special
yeah absolutely this
it's awesome to be a part of this
especially on Remembrance Day it really
hits home to be perfectly honest
Canada in no uncertain terms has
denounced Russia's illegal and
unprovoked War pledging to keep
supporting Ukraine for as long as it
takes 50 and Canada's European air task
force is prepared it has three Hercules
aircrafts and access to the C-17 Globe
master
everybody who's here has signed up uh
with the kingdom forces to make a
difference in the world and this is a
real world opportunity to do that set
for the Long Haul and ready to take to
the sky any day they're called upon
Crystal gemancing Global News Prestwick
Scotland